I feel like I'd recognize these
flavorless pieces of hardboard
anywhere hey guys my name is Morgan and
I used to work at the illustrious
McDonald hey I'm Sarah Beth and I am a
former chick-fil-a employee hi my name
is Joshua I used to work at Popeyes hi
I'm Victor and I'm a former KFC employee
hi my name is Luna I used to work at
Wendy's the perfect french fry is crispy
salty 5:00 to perfection the salt
quality is just that soggy really bad
for you so I'm ready and send the frozen
take the light fries like they have no
comparison because they're so unique
they're the waffles man they're the
hashtags of the fry world they're
amazing
that's it oh-ho waffle fries baby yeah
I'm gonna bite it I don't care
chick-fil-a knows what they're doing I'm
telling you their fights so perfect
they're salted so perfectly too
[Music]
could be a little bit better I feel like
defi could use a little bit more salt a
little bit more flavor all together not
enough salt for me these fries would be
perfect for anyone with high blood
pressure because there isn't a lot of
salt so he was trying to watch your salt
intake these are perfect for you baby
the fries have like no seasoning on them
they're just kind of like greasy
potatoes and I love a good potato
potatoes and all forms but like this is
testing me right now let's just estimate
it's gonna be a ten honestly it's gonna
be a same maybe like a four point seven
six out of ten I would give this like a
1 out of 10 like chicken we're really
like let me done McDonald's hands down
has the best fries they try it just
right the ratio is perfection like you
never need to add anything if you want
to dip it in sauce that's cute
but they're perfect just as they are
other fries really not so sure these
must be good because apparently they
saved the rest of them for themselves on
the galley for so by the smell of these
automatically they're for McDonald's
sometimes these are ones are like you
get like a soft soggy and sometimes you
get like a really crispy one it's just
like all the different textures this
makes me happy
hmm that's not my favorite fries at wok
tastes like an average McDonald's bench
my nothing too crazy they're not crispy
they're all soggy and Limp they have no
flavor Oh ranking mais yeah give them
like I want out of ten like they're like
they're just so like this is like sad
like it's like this fry needs some
support for somebody not me
these are ten is there a ten because
they never fail me I would probably rate
McDonald's french fries a five I would
give these and being pretty generous of
four Popeyes fries are the best because
they have more seasoning than everybody
else's everybody else is just kind of
just fried up with salt but like Popeyes
I don't know what they bred them in but
it's just like super crunchy and they go
the extra mile for you this is what I
like seasoning I don't know maybe
because I'm black I don't know but the
seasoning I can already tell he's gonna
be good I like new no Deezer Deezer
bangin I think they might even fry them
in the oil from the chicken but I'm
picking up some of that there but it is
ridiculously good there's gonna be
comments like this girl just likes every
food you give to her
[Music]
they're good though I mean they've got
way more flavor they're not really
crispy they're kind of like soggy and
squishy and like also greasy like the
chick-fil-a fries but at least they got
seasoning a solid eight pass just on
seasoning alone these are really really
really good ten baby although pretty
much like all I'm looking for in
potatoes is very nice if I had to give
them a rating I'd give them like a four
out of ten I could eat them but I don't
necessarily want to Wendy's fries still
reign supreme and none of y'all can
touch it all right all right what do we
have here these look really really good
honestly on this okay these actually
taste way better than they look they
taste alright so good
whatever it is I won't be going there
these were not for me oh I've made these
to my grandma
if she's not wearing her dentures
they're babies you've heard of digesting
stuff again low in love and salt
actually this one had a little dab of
salt I like that one but yeah grandma
I'll bring you here wherever it is I'll
bring you use it for you I'm gonna do
six and a half out of five
that's exactly oh no six and a half out
of ten I'm sorry I would probably also
have I ranked all of them 10 I probably
raised these right now like a four point
sick I've seen pink Himalayan salt
yeah well all different kind of salts
when you put it around taste like salt
like
[Music]
hey MC fries are absolutely the best
fries there are and it's because they're
not even a fry it's a potato wedge it's
a slice of potato real piece of potato
has the skin on and everything and on
top of that it's perfectly seasoned some
awesome awesome flavors and it's just a
color what everything is perfect about
it oh yes okay these look like chicken
fingers and I'm very taken aback whoever
was working and they find these they
were like they love their job because
these are amazing oh my god okay y'all
you know they're good when you doing
dance the girls you know what I'm
talking about when you do the dance my
feeling about KFC fries it's like why
not just get a biscuit
I honestly like them best out of like
all of them so I kind of like regret
talking smack about KFC's potato wedges
early Earth in this experience so I'm
gonna give them like a solid like
something out of time I'm gonna have to
go with the eighth taste check shape
cute seasoning perfect they just drop
the fry on my left perfect my final
answer yes these are really good
I'd probably give these an eight they
have a lot of good spices they're
crunchy I love the way that they're like
fried and they're they're unique so the
Popeyes French fries one again just like
their chicken sandwich I knew it from
the jump
everybody everybody says go stand in
line for pop eyes right now like we need
to start a huge mass line and get it all
over Twitter because this is ridiculous
like their food is insane
[Music]